IF I WAS GOING TO GO TO
MINNESOTA OR IF HE WOULD COME TO
THE CELTICS AND IT ALL WORKED
OUT.
I CANNOT EVEN LIVE, MAN.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
WAY DID NOT START OFF ON THE
BEST FOOT.
I KNOW YOU WANTED TO TRADE ME
TOO, I KNOW YOU DID.
I WAS ACCUSTOMED TO DOING THINGS
MY WAY.
I DID NOT LIKE SOMEONE COMING
AND TELL ME WHAT TO DO.
HOWEVER, WHEN I STARTED TO
LISTEN TO YOU AND UNDERSTAND
YOUR CRITICISM, THAT IS WHEN I
BECAME GREAT.
SO, THANK YOU.
ALSO, THAT IS WHEN I KNEW YOU
WERE A PLAYERS COACH.
I CAME INTO SHOOT-AROUND ONE
TIME AND I HAD A HANGOVER.
WE WERE RUNNING A PLAY AND IN
THE PLAY, I WAS SUPPOSED TO CUT
THROUGH.
I GO TO ONE NATE.
AND YOU LOOK AT ME -- AND I WAS
LIKE, OH MAN.
I AM COVERING MY BREATH.
I KNOW IT IS BANGING.
I STOPPED SHORT.
AND HE SAID, PAUL, GO HOME AND
BE READY FOR TONIGHT.
GET SOME REST.
AND I SAID, THANKS, COACH AND I
RAN OUT OF THERE.
I HAD 30 THAT NIGHT.
WE WON.
PLAYERS COACH!
[LAUGHTER]